okay sonia
yeah okay thank you good afternoon
members
and welcome to any members of the public
or other councils
uh watching the rochefort district
council's remote planning policy
committee meeting
item number one of the agenda uh
is apologies for absence do we have any
apologies uh
so far sonia no chairman
okay i think uh we seem to be
short of councillor hoyt but i i haven't
seen anything so
hopefully he will join us as we go along
item number two non-members attending
um chairman we have councillors ward
gooding
and wilkinson thank you very much
uh item agenda item three the minutes of
the meeting held
on the 2nd of october i mean it's agreed
members
anybody read agreed anybody not in
agreement please
indicate by raising your blue hand
i don't see any hands right uh item
agenda item four
is any declarations of interest please
members
don't see anything there sonya okay
we'll move on to
agenda item number five which is the new
local plan
evidence base housing an economic land
availability
assessment or as it's now known heller
h e l double a this will be presented by
daniel goodman
team leader strategic planning over to
you daniel
thank you for uh so
this item is obviously on a piece of uh
evidence
uh that that's commonly referred to as
the healer so
um in summary it's an assessment of
parcels of land and their overall
suitability for development
it's quite an important piece of
evidence to inform the local plan
because obviously it allows you
to to understand how much land is likely
to be available
for development in the context of
meeting your your housing
and employment needs uh but also to draw
some general conclusions about
how suitable um and viable different
pieces of land are likely to be
uh so this study has been complete
well commissioned and completed um it
forms
a partial update of the last helar in
2017
in that it does not reassess sites from
that study
but its overall conclusions uh
are that across both studies um that
there are
uh there there is sufficient land to
deliver around
4 300 houses on sites that would meet
current policy
the vast majority of those are existing
allocations
such as the land north of london road
or land hall road but obviously there
are some other sites in there
in the urban area long-term opportunity
sites like
rochefort police station that also
contribute to that figure
and i think this study itself actually
only identified
a supply of around 112 additional
dwellings
so and the main reason for that is that
the vast majority of sites assessed in
it
do fall in the green belt where
obviously it's not possible to say at
this time that they would be suitable
so i suppose that's all i'd probably say
on it i'm happy to take
obviously any questions um but it is
quite a technical piece of work that's
that's
clearly important in understanding land
availability but
i think as we've discussed previously it
doesn't
set policy it doesn't bind the count to
20 decisions
um and uh and it clearly doesn't
um create any greater chance of a site
being granted planning permission than
than otherwise
than otherwise would be the case yes as
you say daniel this is this
is the result of uh two working groups
um with suitable amendments to clarify
various situations that have been
highlighted by members
but uh i see uh councillor mrs mason
would like to ask a question
over to you councilman mrs mason
uh thank you mr chairman it's not such a
question
as an observation and a concern
one i've raised before which has been
partially addressed
um 2.4 he says report relate
to which this report relates to is
therefore being commissioned jointly
with south africa
council for economies of scale to
provide a robust specialist
assessment of the availability and
general suitability of land
in rochester district whilst i
accept that there was nothing wrong with
that being done
i still think that it's poor that that
decision wasn't
made by members anymore particularly
members of the committee
it was left to officers to determine
whether or not we do a joint um
heller and who win i i would like it
uh recorded that for future hellers and
future commissioning
reports of this nature where we're
linking in with another authority should
be
decided by members and not by officers i
understand they've got the financial
wherewithal to do so but i think this is
a policy decision
that should be made by our policy makers
thank you councilman i think we've
already agreed that
what you've just said we took on board
when you raised it on the first occasion
and said that in future we would have
input into this situation
i think it was all also highlighted the
reason we did it with south end on this
occasion
was because we were both at the same
sort of level of progression to our
local plans that was
was the thought behind it but i say i
know when you raised it before i think
we agreed there and then that
in future uh members would be involved
in any decision making of this nature
council can that be recorded then i
guess
that uh council mrs mason
council ahoy yes uh thank you but
apologies for
i'm joining like a little bit of a
problem my end i'm afraid
um i i caught the back end of
that i assume we are on item five at the
moment hopefully yes
fingers crossed yes good um there's just
something i call the back end of um
daniel's um presentation as well and
it's something i i was looking at within
there and it's
possibly linked to other things i
brought brought up within working groups
that this
the header doesn't bind us
to anything he's just considering the
the land that's been put forward however
in the actual report
it does it it comments on the base of
deliverability still
five point five three sorry it's all
much i put it
and this is where i think people really
get confused
over what you we are still i know
there's been
additional wording put in by still
thinking
when you're saying something's
deliverable and developable
it doesn't suggest that it's not being
put in
stone at that point i i think
uh councillor we can go around in
circles on this one i think we've tried
to clarify it
as clearly as we can these are
as i understand it the the words that
you have to use
for this sort of legislation and that's
why we've had to leave it in but that's
why we put in the
explaining uh statements at the
beginning of all these documents
that this is not council policy etc etc
that is the routine routing that we are
wording we have to use
is that is that correct pretty much
daniel
uh yes chair so um it's uh part of the
mppf but also the the
funding practice guidance that relates
to healers specifically
um it is if you like mandatory that land
is categorized based on those
definitions
um and it's you know the basis upon
which
these um these kind of studies are done
is categorizing land as to whether
it is deliverable developable or neither
um and so i think you know the
explanatory text
hopefully goes some way to resolving
that but you know even if we
would want to i don't think we could
transplant that text for anything else
just purely because that would move us
out of
sync with the the guidance that relates
to these assessments
thank you very much do you want to come
back to mrs mason
sorry could i come back there please i
understand your
perhaps frustration with me and say what
i've said but obviously this is the
first public meeting that this has been
in
and that that's why i'm raising at this
point yeah
okay council mrs mason do you want to
come back
yes i would like to come back and i i
agree with what council
hoy said the fact that you've had
private meetings doesn't mean that
things shouldn't be discussed in public
um but going back to the issue of
deliverability
and developable which is clearly i
accept with the office so it's clearly
explained in 3.7
nevertheless we are being asked to
note this report i wonder to
accommodate it uh but we're told it
doesn't bind us it's only for
information basically it's an
evidence-based
report which is in there but could we
have some of that wording
where it says that it holds no status
which is i accept in the report but
could we have that
in the paragraph where we're noting it
so that we're noting it
with the on the understanding that it
has no status
as part of the development plan and i
think that would accommodate
the concerns of some of us
that relate to this report and
also make it very clear for members of
the public
uh i'll just come back counselor mrs
mohsen we haven't been having any
private meetings we've been having
working groups of which you
were present so we haven't had any
private meetings
these groups are not open to the public
this is council mrs mason this has
all been in the working group as you are
aware
and i wasn't this is the first time that
we have had this opportunity
to bring what the presentations from the
working group forward to fall
to the full committee right
i apologize mr chairman if you don't
like the use of the word private
but working groups are not open to the
public nor are their notes
so therefore i'll change the terminology
to working groups
and i think we need some transparency on
such an important uh documentation
i would repeat my request that the
recommendation
that that it proposes that this
committee results to note the heller
it is include noting that it has no
status
as part of the development plan because
i think that will
make things clearer both to members that
are not perhaps
as familiar with the terminology as some
others and also to members of the public
i think we need to
have things as clearly as possible if
you disagree mr chairman
i'm sorry but that's my proposal
well i am sorry because we've had two
working groups where we've tried to iron
out
the wordings that we needed to clarify
these situations
as far as i'm aware everything that was
put forward
to mr goodman to make amendments to have
been included
in the wording that we proposed and i
therefore there is a proposal at the end
of
paragraph nine point one on page 5.4
that the recommendation is that the
committee resolves to note
the header at appendix a and publish it
on the council's website
i would if i may check a second
i haven't seen the documentation other
than that's on the public website
because of issues that the council is
well aware of but i'm not going to
mrs mason i am sorry you can't get the
paperwork but that is no
problem that we can resolve here now i'm
afraid that is an issue that you need to
deal with
prior to these meetings with officers
but we cannot keep going down the road
that you have not had the paperwork when
we get to these meetings i'm very sorry
about that but i can't do anything at
this stage on that issue
yeah mr chairman i'm not expecting you
too far from it i've
actually said that it's nothing we can
deal with here it's something that the
officers haven't been able to resolve
and it's put me at a disadvantage so to
say that i've had the opportunity
um to come back on these things is
incorrect so i do want
clarity and the information that you're
giving to be
accurate and it's not nevertheless i
have
the access to the public documents and i
have been able to read the reports
and again i propose that the resolution
the recommendation is slightly
the wording is slightly altered thank
you
well i i don't believe it would be
appropriate to start changing all the
wording again
the proposal is as the recommendation
says that the
paragraph 9.1 as stated on this document
has been submitted and i hope that
members will
it is noted now we can quite happily
re report uh councillor mason um
that you do not necessarily agree fully
with it
and i'm quite happy for for sonia to
record that
but in the meantime i think we should
publish what has been agreed
up until this point on the website can i
ask you to chair the meeting
and by asking if there's a seconder
before you
decline the motion okay is that a second
that i'll second that counselor
uh sparing for you no problem
thank you which which are you per
second in council western i'm i'm second
in for you
uh as as you as the uh proposal of the
minutes as they are at the moment as uh
going forward uh
thank you thank you very much i've had
my hand raised for some
time okay council ahoy i've been
bypassed
no you haven't been bypassed you're
being asked to speak
now well i'm i'm i'm slightly unclear
what happened because i was here to
second council mrs mason's proposal okay
where you can counsel
well then if we need to take a counselor
weston do you want to come in
not this time uh council i'm sorry
councillor wooden sorry
kevin uh thank you very much indeed
german um
i just want to go back to basics here we
have a report
um where 9.1
is a noting um of the appendix
then if i go to the appendix chairman um
on just the after the heading pages
it is quite clear the advisory notes
i agree totally with what the advisory
note says and i agree with you chairman
that this was talked about at the length
of the working groups
it is almost the first thing that you
read apart from the title pages
if we are now saying that we add as the
minutes
that note we might as well start going
through the whole of the report
adding all the stadium points of the
rest of the report in the minutes
by uh implication uh the minutes
say that they will note the point and or
they they will note
the um the appendix document
uh and i don't really see why we need to
add further information in the minutes
it's an issue over the minutes we're
talking about
not the report itself thank you chairman
thank you
well we now have a proposal from
councillor mrs mason and we have a
second uh
i i think we were going to now have to
go to a vote on this uh
sonia chairman can i just clarify
um my understanding in trying to follow
things is that uh
you you know you've moved the
recommendation um
which uh which council mrs weston has
seconded but i believe that council mrs
mason has moved an amendment to that uh
to that recommendation
asking for additional texts to be
included
but i think you need to allow councillor
hoy uh an opportunity
to to second that uh that proposed
amendment to the motion
so that uh that can be debated if i can
clarify the officer and the procedure
that happened was i moved a motion which
was
the chairman overspoke without asking
for a second or allowing
a second of whom and councillor hoy was
correct his hand was up
counselor nominees uh western sorry hand
was not
up um and then he then took a second
there on his own emotion so
actually the first motion was ignored
the motion on the table
is the one that kelsey sparring put and
i'm putting we'll have to now put an
amendment to that
um to my original motion because it
wasn't taken
in a democratic or sequential manner
so we will now vote uh sonia on
mrs mason's amendment seconded by
councillor hawaii
uh he's correct would you like to
clarify the amendment
uh yes please and um and i think um i
think out of courtesy
um it would be good to allow councillor
hoy the opportunity to
to to speak to seconding that amendment
uh chairman
okay
mr chairman would you like me to clarify
i thought i thought counselor was going
to speak but he hasn't uh
hasn't indicated that he wishes to speak
sorry
i think there's a lot of confusion going
on i thought counselor mrs mason was
first going to clarify
the amendment and then i'm happy to say
okay well let's go down that road then
mr councillor mrs mason
over to you thank you mr chairman right
for clarity
the only thing that we're suggesting on
the report to be
altered is the recommendation 9.1
9.1 it is proposed that the committee
resolves to note the heller
in the um knowledge that it holds no
status as part of the development plan
okay thank you
councillor hi do you want to speak thank
you chairman just briefly
um i'm i'm second seconding
this on the basis of um things i've said
in the past both in the working groups
and outside
in the clarities needed for residents
um if this is in the recommendation it's
there very clearly for residents
to see um makes it much plainer than it
would otherwise they don't have to go
hunting through
through the um appendices or for the the
full report to find this
this bit to you or to me or to other
members of this committee it might be
quite straightforward to find
but it isn't necessary to to residence
or the understanding i think it just
gives a clarity
and i think clarity is very is is really
required in this
on this subject thank you well you've
you've heard the
uh the comments members you've also
heard
a counselor uh
wooden's comments that he believes as i
do
and a motion that i've said or comments
i've made
that we've already covered this aspect
fully in the
articles that we've added to the
preceding parts
of this report it's now i guess uh sonia
whether members wish to vote to support
council mrs mason's
amendments or if we stay with what is
already
on the working papers that have been
sent out
so i'll leave you to take the vote on
whether we go with the amendment or
leave it as it is members can i first
clarify
can you please uh click on your race
hand icon if you want a recorded vote
no in which case um if you could please
uh click
on your raise hand icon if you wish to
vote in favor of the amendment to the
motion
can you please vote my uh record my
voters in favor of the
amendment please certainly can you note
mine as well please indeed
um and if you could please um i'll
remove those for you
um and now if um those against the
amendment to the motion if you could
please click on your raise hand icon
thank you
lauren if you could take those down for
me please
chairman there were two votes uh in
favor of the motion
and four against so the uh the amendment
to the motion is lost
okay thank you do we now have to have
another vote
to support the statement already that
paragraph 9.1 or is that
okay if you would like to uh i proposed
and councillor west in a second
that the st what is already been
proposed at paragraph 9.1 on page
5.4 it is proposed that the committee
resolves to note the header
at appendix a and publish it on the
council's website
so again again chairman if members could
please
click on their race hand icon if they
are in
favor of the motion as moved by cancer
sparing
thank you if you could take those raise
hands down for me please
thank you and then if those who would
like to vote against
the uh the the motion is moved by cancer
sparing
if you could please click on your race
hand icons now
if you wish to abstain if you if you'd
like to click on your raised hand icons
thank you chairman that motion is uh
is is approved thank you members
we will now move on to agenda item
number six
the new local plan evidence base urban
capacity
study back over to you daniel
thank you chair um the urban classy
study uh
similarly is an evidence-based report
that's been prepared
to inform council's new local plan uh
similarly to the healer it uh it is
about land
availability and capacity so again it's
about informing a judgment of
um how much housing can be accommodated
in the district under certain
assumptions
um and really uh the
the study uh has looked at uh
the council the district's urban areas
all land outside of its greenbelt and
sought to identify the capacity of
uh of available land for housing um
over the next 20 years i think an
important
point just to emphasize and something
that that has been mentioned
previously is uh there are certain
aspects of the report which are
relatively
um hypothetical or they're conditional
on
um decisions that um that
the study isn't intending to prejudice
um particularly when it's
exploring the capacity of land um
in a in a sense that wouldn't meet
current policy
so um notwithstanding the fact that the
council could make a decision in the
future
um to um to
seek to maximize that urban capacity i
think it's important to emphasize that
that some of those figures do not meet
current policy
and therefore limited weight should be
attached to them
just to just to conclude um really um
the urban capacity study concludes that
there's around
2800 homes that could be delivered on
urban sites
on again deliverable or developable
pieces of land
um that compares to obviously the the
figures in the heli it's slightly lower
because the healer is inclusive of
non-urban land
um and i think just just the point that
i mentioned before just to
just say that again i mean 1 700 homes
identified in the study as being
theoretically possible on
sites such as existing allocations
however that is described as theoretical
because
the study hasn't done a detailed
assessment of the impacts of that
decision
and it makes no implication that that
would be a sustainable option
other than to say that in simple
mathematic terms if you like a higher
number of houses could fit
on those sites so that's that's all i'd
like to say really on that
at the moment um chair of
again i'm happy to answer questions on
that study
um as previously thank you daniel uh
well members i think we
we've been through an awful lot of this
before in the two working groups are
there any further questions for daniel
i can't see anything then paragraph 9.1
on page 6.6 there is a recommendation
sorry council mrs mason i hadn't seen
your hand
no that was a problem something come up
on the laptop that just said i
wish i had had to update something uh so
i couldn't get on to
um to actually
indicate i lost my reference on this i
think it was 7.88 i'm just uh
looking for it to see where the issue is
yes if if i refer you to
not on the actual report but on the
appendix the
six page 6.43
and just so you're aware mr chairman
this has been raised on more than one
occasion just so you're aware of it
6.43 7.88
we have here i mean it's not a big issue
but it's a very important issue when
we're talking about public
clarity and information and the newer
members of this committee won't
realize that this issue has been raised
year in year out
again and again and has been failed to
be addressed
and 7.88 seo one
okay but look at the directions scr4
scr8 south east ashington is in roach
north and rural
when this is published residents look at
south hawkwell
we do not have a south hawk world
designation we do not have southeast
washington
in the middle of roach north and rural
either if it comes to that
so those are just two examples now i
realize that these
descriptions have been used for some
years
but we've also asked for some years for
there to be greater clarity
and to be the walled or to put the
actual location in other words
if you must call it south hawkward when
it's not
put hawk or west walden if you've west
rockford put the world in so that
residents know what we're talking about
this has the presumably
unintentional way of hiding where the
real locations are
and it means that residents that read
this very lengthy report
if i if i was not a counselor and i read
this report i'd go down and say oh
there's nothing that affects me
that's good so i thought well he's right
next door to me and i live in west hawk
so i would like that address we have
requested it
before on many occasions and it's
further down as well
in the report it's a small point but i
think when we're talking about
transparency
we're talking about a document that's
going to be made public
we want to make sure that the public
have the best possible chance of
understanding it
thank you thank you councilman
councillor wooden uh thank you chairman
uh i put my hand up before um knowing
the point that
council mrs mason was going to make and
i totally agree with her the uh
descriptions of our areas should be
current and topical and understandable
to the
uh directly understandable to the
readership so that is a point in support
of mrs mason
um but the point i was actually going to
make was without
dare i say laboring from the previous
point the reason i couldn't support them
but the amendment for the motion
was because the minutes and the reports
are not published on our website
as such it is these documents but the
advisory note on 6.9 i believe should be
boldened up and putted up so that it is
much more obvious
to the readership because
notwithstanding our previous discussion
it is an important factor and unlike the
previous report the heller report
uh this it's just in the normal text so
i would ask that it is bold enough to
draw the importance
uh of the point to uh uh the readership
thank you chairman
okay can you clarify that um both
reports are on the website that's where
i'm reading them from
so but i've got no objection with what
kelsey wilson said but both reports are
on the website
and if i may just make one other point
uh councilwood and if you'd excuse me
for that the other thing i have found is
i'm reading them on the website
you can enlarge the forms which is fine
for the written word
you enlarge the maps they become totally
indistinct i think for a public document
we need to have
the clarity on those maps so that when
members of the public
enlarge them which they're bound to do
they don't
lose the definition it's a small point
but again it's an important
one for transparency and public
perception of clarity
thank you thank you councillor mrs
weston
oh thank you chairman yeah i i'm i like
councillor woods and i agree with
council mrs mason wholeheartedly and we
did discuss this before
yeah we did say and we've got to be
careful how we call these walls because
our residents will get concerned and
upset so
i i totally accept what uh council mrs
mason is saying chairman
okay uh members can we agree
in principle that we go along with the
recommendation that we publish
but that uh mr goodman takes on board
and officers take on board the comments
that have just been made
and before anything further is done
those amendments are incorporated
in the recommendation that goes forward
that these are published
on the website or the website is julia
mended to reflect these views
is that acceptable members
um councillor mrs lumley
is indicating chairman yes june i just
wanted to
um agree with with actually what's been
said because i
i made the point about the major
developments being
labeled as rayleigh when they're they're
actually in
um and yeah it's great marketing value
to say
they're rayleigh but but actually
they're not um
so i thought i had read somewhere where
some of that had been referenced
now but that may be in in more local
later documents rather rather than these
so perhaps daniel before you
uh you can speak to the four members
that have
have highlighted this or or mrs mason or
councillor wooden
to make sure that this is clarified
before we do anything further but that
in principle that we
we endorse that this is published on the
website but
as with highlighting the issues that
have just been raised
okay members are in agreement with that
okay moving on members
agenda item number seven which is the
local plan
a local new local plan evidence based
green belt study again daniel over to
you
thank you chair so um again uh the
greenbot study is an evidence-based
document to inform the new local plan
um it's uh quite an important piece of
evidence
in the sense that uh clearly a lot of
the undeveloped land in rochford is in
the greenbox
and we obviously have growth pressures
that mean that
we're we're likely to have to critically
explore you know whether it is
appropriate to release
uh greenbelt land for development so
the the overarching purpose of the study
is to consider
uh the relative contribution that
different areas of land make to
the five greenbelt purposes and those
five greenbox purposes are
set out in national policy um
and clearly as you'd expect there's a
degree of variation across the district
in terms of
how much different air parts the
district contribute differently to those
five purposes
so the studies outputs
do give a harm rating
to areas of land that landowners and
developers
have put forward for for development if
you like
i think it's important just to say that
there's no implication that just because
a piece of land
um would only have a modest impact
if it was released that that makes it a
good candidate for
release and on the other hand
just because a site would have a
significant impact that makes it a bad
candidate because i think
we all accept that when decisions are
made about development you know you have
to take into account
a wide array of different factors and it
could be
you know in theory the most sustainable
piece of land in the entire district
from a housing perspective um happens to
be in quite a
quite a precious area of greenbelt
conversely
um a a poorly performing piece of green
belt
might be unsuitable for other reasons
you know for example it could be
underwater six months of the year so i
think it's important that not too much
weight is attached to individual site
conclusions but obviously it's an
important piece of evidence to consider
amongst other studies when the council
has to make decisions in the future
and again i'm happy to take any
questions thank you
councillor hoy
thank you chairman sorry for the delays
in my pressing unmute
um just a small point and very parochial
again
as always with albridge i know that
you're
proposing to remove some green belt
classification along the
southern edge of the river crouch
um roughly from the
main slipway to the yacht club slipway
i know it's a small area i know it's
probably unlikely to be developed
i just find it this is a
obviously you've you've got the um
what it's called the coat coastal
protect
protection area yeah boulders um
i i think if we are removing
a a bit small but to my mind important
area of green belt which
would which would be quite important in
keeping the openness of the area
in my view i think it's quite dangerous
um
obviously there are this ball there's a
yacht club and a
and a um and the the anchoring
on this bank which could encourage
in additional development
in that area i'm just a bit worried
about what it the
it is quite small but it has quite a big
benefit to keeping the openness of the
area in my opinion that's what i want to
say
i think i can keep rambling for ages
about it but i don't want to that's the
point i'm trying to make
may i come back on that yeah sure i'd
appreciate it
um just for clarity i i mean i'm
assuming and please correct me if i'm
wrong that we're talking about
um the section that's to do with um
minor alterations to the green belt um
rather than a piece a parcel of land
that's been identified elsewhere
i think um i think it's just important
to clarify
that the study is not in itself um
changing obviously the green belt status
of any of that land i think
the purpose of that exercise is um that
the consultant that's done the
study has looked at um areas
um where i i hesitate
i hasn't used the word but i'm going to
use it anyway where they're
perhaps their anomalies sometimes these
can be
drawing errors where the green belt has
been drawn
you know perhaps in a pre-digital time
and
it it leaves perhaps anomalies and
i don't know whether or not um
well i suspect that um
this is an area where in the
consultant's opinion
um the the case for it being greenbelt
is in some way undermined by
um by something like i've described but
i think it
i think what's important to emphasize i
suppose is that
this this document does not in any way
stains change the green part status of
that land the only way green belt land
can ever be
changed is obviously for the examination
of a local plan
and so it's totally in the council's
gift
to not put that piece of land forward as
a green belt amendment
when the local plan goes to be submitted
to government
if the you know in the opinion of of
council
um actually the consultant's opinion on
that piece of land
is incorrect um i suppose that's true of
all of this evidence really when it's
done by consultant you know it's a
professional opinion that
we can weigh up but again you know to
use that word again we're not we're not
bound by by what they've suggested
provided obviously we can
we have a good rationale from for um for
for going against it so i i suppose
i i totally understand the point that
that you're raising
and i think if council agree with you
um then you know there's no pressure if
you like to include that
as um as a green belt alteration
but clearly the consultant has put it
forward that something in their opinion
is
you know either anomalous or um very
weakly performing
i hope that makes more sense than it
probably
sounded like no thank you daniel that's
um
um what i wanted to hear thank you
council mrs mason
yeah thank you mr chairman i i think
daniel's
covered part of my concerns that the i
must admit long bells always ring when
you hear of anything being removed from
the green belt
and on the understanding that this
doesn't is just a recommendation
and not one that's going to necessarily
go any further
yeah i'll accept that but the the one
thing is just a small question i'd like
you put the green belt um definitions as
strong or weak
who decides on that i mean it sounds
quite subjective
to me um are there any objective
assessments on strength and weaknesses
of the value of greenbelt or is it just
a subjective
experience shall we say measurement
because it does
seem that we're putting quite a lot of
weight on that i know it doesn't
stop or promote development but on the
other hand
again going back to the public if they
see
those categories they could be concerned
so i just like greater understanding of
the
that the who determines strong or weak
and how you know is there an objective
assessment
have i clarified that right daniel yeah
yes so um in the study there are
two main stages i think the first um the
first stage is
effectively the the consultant you know
and
um it is their professional judgment
you know i suppose they have done these
up and down the country hence why we're
comfortable going with them but it it is
a judgment
have parcelled up the district and then
there are individual assessments of how
strongly or weakly
each of those parcels contributes to
each of the five purposes of greenbelt
and because those purposes are things
like um
preventing the coalescence of
neighbouring towns
you know i mean it it is a judgment from
that consultant as to whether or not
a piece of land you know let's say it's
it's um one of those areas of land that
are between kind of rayleigh and
eastwood
you know that might quite clearly be
strongly
performing against that criterion and
then
you might say actually a piece of land
out by pagglesham clearly isn't as
strong
so there's there isn't really a
quantifiable
way of doing that exercise it is it is a
judgment but obviously it's
it's not a judgment where they have
um tried to if you like
assess all five in one go and you've got
maybe averaging
out and it's all gone a bit um it's all
quite hard to follow
the fact that they have assessed it
against all five individually means it's
quite
quite easy in theory to um
dig deeper you know should council want
to um
if you like interrogate the the reasons
why a
certain piece of land has reached a
certain score it should be
relatively easy to track back the
consultant's logic
i think the second stage is obviously
the harm assessment and that's
um a reflection of how
strongly the parcel has performed in the
first stage
but they also introduce other again you
know subjective factors
such as you know containment for example
where
you know if you've got a piece of land
that's uh bordered on three sides by the
urban area
then it's quite hard to say that that's
a that would be harmful to the green
belt
in relative terms because um actually on
three sides
it's already urbanized if that makes
sense so i think
the easiest way to answer the question
is it is a subjective
professional judgment but i would hope
that
the multi-staged aspect of study means
that
should we get to a point in the next
year or two where we
want to interrogate the performance of
pieces of land in more detail
um that the study would allow us to do
that um
quite quite easily
i was very concerned about the large
charge that they wanted to remove on the
easter the b1013 which
i accept what you're saying but that
would
create a coalescence so which is
partly why i was asking the question
because it this
doesn't seem
it's concerning put it that way but on
the understanding that this is
subjective and i suppose there's nothing
we can do
about it is the consultants that uh
south end or we chose i don't know who
chose them but um
we're employed and it's their opinion
but i i'm concerned it doesn't
take into account local opinion but
presumably that will come later on in
the uh
state of the development of the plan
thank you councilman daniel can i can i
just recall i mean this is what we keep
putting in the front of
the documentation this is a
standard report that we have received we
will
anything that we want to alter will have
to come to full council
to make any alterations that full
council deem appropriate it is not just
because they put it in the report but
it's statutory move anything anything
that they recommend
we will consider on a case-by-case basis
as and when it arises is that correct
yes so i think that's true of all
evidence really is
you know it's there to inform decisions
um it's not there to make decisions
but clearly when you do make decisions
um
you want your evidence to support them
to a large extent but
that's not again yeah i mean it's not
about binding the council to any
decision
uh greenbelt released can only happen on
the adoption of a sound
local plan and you know that means
council approval probably on multiple
occasions
plus a government inspector approving it
so
um certainly the evidence is is only
there to advise i think it's probably
the best word i can use to describe it
as well
okay members um i think we've we've
reiterated that the situation and
clarified that nothing will happen
without full council
rather stamping it approving it
whichever phrase you want so
on that basis there is a recommendation
paragraph 9.1
on page 7.4 is proposed the committee
resolves to note the greenbelt study
at appendix a and publish it on the
council's website or members in
agreement
chairman i think council award is uh
wishing to speak
go going in uh thank you very much today
chairman uh it's just picking up
on what council wooden said about the
advisory note
uh on this one again it's in italics
quite small
can you can we make sure that throughout
all the documents
it's the same type all bold
aerial whatever you want to use it but
please keep it the same type
and and it stands out so it's very much
in the the reader's face the moment he
opens that document
up if you can do that please daniel
thank you
on that basis members we'll move on
taking that comment on on all items
move on to uh agenda item number eight
which is the new local
plan evidence base landscape character
sensitivity and capacity study again
uh daniel
thank you chair so uh landscape
character sensitivity capacity study
it's uh it's another piece of technical
evidence that's been assessed
similar in a sense to the greenbelt
study in that it's looking
um at the performance of different parts
of the district against
um again a subjective methodology
this time it looks at the character
sensitivity and capacity of different
landscapes and
uh townscapes as well uh which i think
which i think is quite important
um so similar to the greenbelt study
again it's not about binding the council
to any decision it's not about
saying that this piece of land is um
as a matter of fact you know more
appropriate for development than
that piece of land but again um it
it does provide the consultant's
professional opinion on
what kind of contribution um different
areas the district make
to um landscape character uh how
sensitive and
how sensitive those um landscapes are
and their capacity for development you
know and that in a sense is
you know how much development could be
accommodated before it starts to
actually harm that landscape
so um it's again there just to inform
the new local plan um it's not there to
bind any decisions
um but it's another thing like the
greenbelt study and
other studies that members have seen
before and in the future
there to be considered as part of any uh
strategy formation
when it comes to um looking at different
areas of the district
um that's i suppose all i'm all i
probably would say at this point on that
on the study
thank you thank you daniel well i think
we're we're pretty much back to
groundhog day uh members with
you know the situation council mrs mason
yeah it's just one point the point that
i raised on the other
issue that these i'm reading
these maps and the documents from the
council's seamless
website and as will members of the
public be
the issue that we have on on the maps
is when they're enlarged again they're
indistinct and that does need to
be resolved before these i mean these
are draft documents that's fair enough
but before they're
permanently put in the public domain
they really should be tidied up because
if you're asking for someone to look at
something
they're going to want to focus in on
their local area
if they try to focus in on their local
area they're just going to get a great
splodge
and that is not the i would think the
state of profession that we want to put
on our websites that
people can't read i mean even the words
involved
like um i can't read it i think it's
found this world
which is the wrong name anyway but
nevertheless
if um yeah it can't be read
so something needs to be done by uh i t
people to resolve this on a
permanent basis but other than that mr
chairman i've got no
comment just a concern that we are
putting documents out there that can't
be read
okay thank you councilman daniel will
you take that on board and uh
sort that out with it if it's if it's at
all possible or what we can do to
mitigate this situation yes i think
probably what it is is that when
i have been sending these files around
i've been needing to compress them
because of email limits and things like
that the actual
core documents themselves have much
higher resolution images and those are
the ones that go on the website thank
you very much
well on that basis and and if you could
make sure that any maps
and uh areas to be defined and also the
the bold print that the precede of any
documents are doing we now come to
paragraph on this recommendation
paragraph 9.1 on
page 8.4 it is proposed the committee
resolves that the landscape character
sensitivity and
capacity study attached to appendix a be
noted as evidence and published on the
council's website
is our members in agreement with that
okay members thank you very much indeed
that concludes today's meeting thank you
for attending
and i declare the meeting closed thank
you
thank you thank you thank you chairman